here now Stephen Miller former White
House senior advisor under President
Trump and Monica Crowley former
assistant Secretary of the Treasury uh
Stephen
um they're not asleep at the wheel
they're wide awake and they're driving
us right off the cliff it looks like
whether it's the Ukraine uh money
spigots never going to turn off or any
of the Dei or woke stuff they're doing
and meanwhile it looks like there could
be a you know continued run on some of
these Regional Banks
well you're right Laura it's all
deliberate and it's a mistake to think
that they're too busy or they're too
distracted or they're too confused they
have an agenda and you mentioned it they
implemented this executive order they
wrote it four weeks ago the Biden signed
that says Equity or Dei is the core
mission of every single agency in the
federal government in other words they
want to run the country the way the
executives at Silicon Valley Bank ran
that financial institution take huge
risky gambles on crazy woke projects
crazy climate projects virtue signaling
with no Financial Integrity no Financial
soundness underneath and this whole
country is going to go the way of
Silicon Valley Bank if we don't change
direction
and Monica you'll love this because you
know you were so well you're up so early
when you were working at the treasury
Department that you worked so many long
hours but ahead of Biden's speech this
morning Jen sake gave us all some
insight into his rigorous schedule
now it's important to note President
Biden does nothing at 9 A.M he is a
night owl so the fact that he is doing
this at 9am anyway speaks to how vital
the White House recognizes it is for him
to have his voice out there
Monica are they kidding me he's supposed
to get a gold star for doing something
at 9 00 a.m this is hard to believe
so his former press secretary is now
admitting on National Television that
the presidents of the United States is
not functional at nine o'clock in the
morning and she blames that on him being
a night owl but they're all of these
stories saying no he goes to bed early
so I mean we have a part-time president
who's in the process of deliberately
destroying the United States of America
Stephen is right we have been making
this point a long time if this all
weren't deliberate from the takedown of
the US economy the wide open border
cities and collapse Sky High inflation
sky high crime rates he would have
changed course by now and he hasn't so
again they have set this country on a
trajectory of absolute and utter ruin to
Stephen's point about equity and his
executive order shooting this through
the entire United States government all
of the executive branch offices this is
cultural and economic Marxism there is
no other way of putting it woke
d-e-i-e-s-g all of these things social
justice they're all euphemisms for
cultural and economic Marxism and this
is where we are this long march of the
Socialists through our institutions over
many decades the chickens are coming
home to Bruce now these are all of these
institutions it's no longer about their
core Mission whether it's banking or
running the federal government it is
about the fundamental transformation of
the nation and now here we are
now Stephen another alarming Point
Michael schellenberger reported today
that during a conference call about the
Silicon Valley Bank bailout Senator Mark
Kelly asked representatives from the FED
on the treasury Department and the FDIC
if they had a way to censor information
on social media to prevent a run on the
banks
Stephen whether it's covid or you know
something with Ukraine or or you know
their their racism uh you know
racializing everything Obsession they
want censorship period not they don't
need an excuse to censor
that's right they wrote The Playbook
with covet and now they're using it for
everything you can't question their
narrative on Ukraine you certainly can't
question their narrative on critical
race Theory and gender Theory and now
you can't even question Joe Biden's
banking policies without Democrat
Senators calling for you to be censored
this is Marxism as Monica said this
isn't the old school liberalism that we
grew up with this is Hardcore
authoritarian Marxism trying to squelch
the free speech and the freedom of
Americans am I just had that now that we
know that Joe Biden doesn't do anything
at all until nine o'clock in the morning
it's safe to say that we know if enemies
attack us it'll be sometime between six
and eight o'clock in the morning in all
likelihood because apparently Joe Biden
will not be able to get out of bed
all right Monica would uh Steve mnuchin
would have agreed to this kind of a
bailout of the bank
I don't know that's an interesting
question
um look this bank is Silicon Valley it's
green energy all the way the heavy
Democratic connections including to
Maxine Waters including to Gavin Newsom
so I I think I look these are all very
difficult political calculations when
you're in an emergency but we do know
that there are heavy Democratic ties
between this Bank the founders of the
bank and heavy Democratic players so
it's no surprise his team are moving in
yeah we need subpoons are subpoena this
get to the bottom of it
yeah absolutely it's got to be
consequences for this nonsense and a
republican shouldn't be for these
bailouts period end of story Stephen
Monica great to see you both hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else